this week on quad riga germany under
pressure new deal for greece shuttle
diplomacy for Alexis tsipras the new
far-left Greek Prime Minister was on a
tour of European capitals this week to
drum up support from EU partners his
government wants an end to the austerity
measures imposed by international
lenders his finance minister Yanis
varoufakis has also been making the
rounds calling for a debt restructuring
program that would buy Athens more time
to get its finances in shape so far
Germany has ruled out debt cancellation
for Greece but Chancellor Angela Merkel
says she's looking forward to meeting
tsipras at a Brussels summit next week
will Berlin agree to renegotiate Greek
debt your host this week Melinda crane
hello and welcome to quadriga that
shuttle diplomacy this week ultimately
brought two of the main protagonists in
the Greek debt drama face to face as
Greece's finance minister met his German
counterpart can common ground be found
what could a new deal for Greece look
like and will it come in time that's
what we want to talk about today with
three people who've been following the
events very closely it's a pleasure to
welcome orica Hammond she's a political
correspondent and business editor at the
Berlin daily newspaper the tots and she
began her career as a banker and
Friedrich Stalin is with us again a warm
welcome to you he has his own consulting
office for many years he worked with
Germany's business weekly VHF swaha as
bureau chief in Bonn when it was capital
and later on here in Berlin and it's a
pleasure to welcome back Theodore kuba
ka's he reports freelance from Berlin on
areas including European financial
markets and foreign policy he has worked
with the Greek daily oliviero tibia as
well as for real media and the business
newspaper in Mar Vista fritters Taillon
last week we were hearing fairly
confrontational rhetoric out of Athens
at least that's how the media in many
places were interpreting it this week
Greece is clearly signaling that it does
want to talk do you think a workable
compromise
is in the making well an American system
would say that is the hundred and twenty
six thousand dollar question I don't
know I doubt that from the point we have
seen to now there will be a compromise
very very soon because well there's so
much argument on on the site of the
European community especially what they
do fear is not the cut again of they do
fear infection there are other nations
like Portugal like Island like the
Spanish and the French all the Italians
who would like any sort of getting down
away from austerity policies oh that's
what we always wanted for so I think the
government here will be rather cautious
in compromising you see it or we cammin
certainly in many many other places
there's a chorus a veritable Greek
chorus of voices condemning austerity
saying it's not working is the viewpoint
here in Berlin shifting at all do you
think that German leaders are now
prepared to make some compromises on
this dogma that many people see as their
work well you know it compromised in
fact technically would be very easy
because even now Greece isn't paying any
money I mean it's just true what wrong
track is the new finance minister chris
says Greece is bankrupt and right now
officially they pay interest rates on
their loans but in fact you know make
new loans to pay the interest rates and
these new loans also come from the
European so in fact the Europeans are
paying for themselves and Greece is
already out of the game and so I'm very
much in favor of the haircut you know i
think is right now a write-off of sun
the day yeah some of the dirtiest and
because you know it wouldn't harm anyone
because as I said the Europeans pay for
themselves anyway so your point of view
but what about the leaders here it is
not sounded eager to go along with the
right off yeah exactly so it's not about
it's not a question of money it's a
question of symbolism I mean and I think
that mr. Tyrion is quite correct the
question is no longer what happens to
grease the questions more yeah if we if
they have an official hair
cat or riding off of some debts what
will the Portuguese say what will the
Spanish say will everything change
within the European Union and I think
that's the eurozone and I think that's
what mrs. Marko fears te adoro Caracas
you were here with us last week on the
program and you were one of the first to
say look this rhetoric is not nearly as
confrontational as many people think it
sounds now of course Greece is extending
the signal saying we want to talk what
do you think about the reaction that the
Greek leaders have been getting as they
make their way from one European capital
to the next is it in fact disappointing
from a Greek point of view the reaction
within grace is what was expected people
many people think that they are being
you know giving leeway and not being
Stern enough the reaction from France
Italy will see Germany and it has been
that of let's say noble noble distancing
and that makes a compromise I think even
harder to achieve it doesn't seem that
mr. tsipras has enough allies in Europe
to pressure anybody Germany all the
Eurogroup oh never in order to achieve
what he wants fast and effectively were
you for example surprised by the
reaction in France many people thought I
think that there would be more
solidarity shown by French leaders than
in fact was the case well before the
elections yes everybody would expect
this wave of democratic uprising to have
other people follow that is not the case
at this point that is not the case at
this point we've got lots of elections
coming this year in Europe and it will
be very interesting to see after
the conclusion of the negotiations of
Greece with its lenders and partners and
allies it would be very interesting to
see what will happen in what's a Finland
or Portugal or the United Kingdom in the
elections much more short-term we saw a
reaction very quickly from the European
Central Bank following talks between its
head Mario Draghi this week and the
greek Finance Minister that surely must
have been a disappointing reaction for
the Greek leaders because the european
central bank said very clearly they will
not continue a special exemption that
they had made allowing Greece to
basically give its own bonds as security
for further loans Friedrich Talon tell
us a little bit about what that means
the consequences of that apparently
quite a strong noble distancing on the
part of the ECB but yes it's the policy
where's the policy towards Greece to be
more considerate more generous and
prolonging this but that's what the new
finance minister once that these sort of
credits go forever and was so the
interest rate down to one percent it's
like that's a haircut that's another
word for the haircut that's what the
Greeks I a finance ministers also said
well you shouldn't use the word haircut
because that it doesn't go down well in
Germany or in other European countries
we need another formula this is leather
like the political class in a lot of
countries knives likes to use the word
the game of words and find your words
with but I mean what else did athens
expect when they first set the tree as
consisting out google group and European
Bank and the International money there
were no longer respected guests in as
it's what you expect to god Roy guy up
in now access to Troy kya but and if you
tell them folks you should not land here
anymore but with your airplanes well and
you expect these bangs all part of these
troika's going to say welcome we
continue I
we have German say whatever you cry into
the wood comes out of it as an echo this
is part of the echo or make a ham
instinct yeah go ahead I agree the work
haircut is a taboo for for Europe but
the word troika's a taboo for Greece
after six years of austerity so a
compromise should have another form of
helping wedding dinner another kind of
another kind of formulation which will
allow the Greeks to feel that they are
respected again not for being bankrupt
of course but for being European
citizens in difficulty okay is it a
semantic issue mr. taelen just said
another wording would greece be
satisfied if the three entities which
have been supervising the greek bailouts
under the name of the or the nickname of
the troika if we simply were to call
them something else sort of like that
the former singer prince who later
became known as the singer formerly
known as I think that's not exactly the
point the semantics is very important in
politics we all know that it's mostly
marketing that's a Greek word but of
what I know what the Greek government is
proposing now is to have at least a a
part of democratic legitimization in
this governing body which means
involving the European Parliament
perhaps or the representatives of their
elected politicians do you think the
troika is our non-elected yes absolutely
so you mean the IMF is not elected oh
but there oh no no no no not at the
troika like a troika is a the
representatives at the unelected
representatives of the ECB the European
Central Bank the International Monetary
Fund and the European Commission with
all these people deciding in these units
financial units or bags I come from
pockets re-elected there is no one who
comes by
is the government appointing him I might
wanna they themselves are not elected
but of course you know as soon as Greece
got money from outside and it was
decided by democratic governments in the
eurozone that Greece is going to have
money of course you know one can
understand that the government's wanted
to have some control what happens with
the money in Greece so and of course now
yeah and stand Amell and now that it
agrees says well we don't want to have
the troika anymore in our country and
the ECB is part of it of course it's
very in a way is that what the ECB
presumably is reacting to when it says
we no longer see the will to reform and
therefore we cannot continue with this
exception well I think no because it's
even worse you know they don't have the
possibility to help because the ECP can
only give loans if there is a kind of
treaty or agreement but agrees decided
not to have great treaty anymore they
all want to renegotiate all treaties so
for the ECB there's no longer
surrounding email out bail out and there
and the debts Greek Greece has to pay
back so for the for the ECB in a way
it's really hard because there is no
legal foundation to say well we just
continue paying out money to Greece
without there being any treaty and
without Greece being ready to somehow
let the troika into the country I mean
there's no control there's no legal
basis so what is the ECB to do what
happens of course is that and I think
that might be a chance now that the ECB
says well we won't pay any money anymore
to Greece it's not only putting pressure
on Greece it's also putting pressure on
the rest of the eurozone because I mean
if the Greek just went bankrupt in a
very kotik way I mean that is what would
happen then it would be extremely
dangerous with the whole of the eurozone
there's grease somehow drops out your
focus this week of course Greek banks
several of them have been looking very
very wobbly indeed what does this ECB
decision not to allow Greece to continue
getting money via its own bonds of
security what does that mean short term
for the Greek economy for the banks
short term for the Greek banks doesn't
mean much because their exposure to
sovereign debt because that's the only
debt that is excluded is something like
21 billion euros which when used as
collateral with a ECB in order to get
loans get financing they have a haircut
of forty percent they have lots of bonds
of the EFSF and other bonds which they
confront and also they have access to
the emergency lending assistance which
means they've gone which will be gone at
the end of the month exactly everywhere
28-7 holiday under them so but that is
not the forum there is a problem that
can arise even faster than that and that
could be a bank run of what is left of
money in Greek banks because we had a
bank drip for in last three months two
and a half months a tens of billions of
years have gone out there's people who
are living under austerity went from
there it don't have your money left they
don't have money that service the upper
five percent of that is well that is a
question but I mean if Europeans look
closely on the Greek Constitution they
find out that by Constitution the sort
of ship owners which is the upper crust
of the financial all politically need in
this country is exempt from taxes and
that has not been changed it's still
exempt and if we've heard that in fact
the work that the EU has been doing with
Greece to basically institutional reform
that it has been showing fruit that in
fact the tax system is more effective
other European countries said this week
that they will help Greece to find tax
evaders and basically get that money
back are those not steps to actually
remedying some of the the terrible bad
governance issues that we've seen in the
past definitely and that would be unfair
not to say there are steps forward to be
seen but then
not good enough everybody said well the
broad population is going to pay all the
burden the austerity he thought normal
worker than the rest the income of a
Polish worker is thirty percent less
than of a Greek worker in the same
position and Poland has worked out of it
I always come back to the point that
other nations have done this and from
the police start it was not very easy
and the Portuguese was almost as
miserable as he fought nobody is
responsible for historical reasons but
they have come out of it and then
everybody said thank you why are those
the only one who got to cut in 2012 for
122 billion euros private owners and now
they come again wherever is the end
where the light at the end of the tunnel
and the Greek government does things
which are strangely the finance minister
has set two days ago we were not
following the regulations and treaties
and contracts which the former
government has with other European
countries it's against democracy I mean
this is a very very difficult stand to
say what the former government legally
elected Democratic did in international
context is no longer law for us I then
you you shut up a lot of possible donors
I didn't think they said they ever said
there they're not going to repay or
stand by what but by their obligations
that's what mr. varvakis yet I said
yesterday that and that's not the point
because even if Chancellor Merkel and
finance minister Choi Blair fall madly
in love with what mr. tsipras and
missile mr. varoufakis propose and if
they say okay we give you whatever you
want let's go on Greece will have the
same problem in three four five years
because it's a systemic problem and
within the eurozone as it is Greece has
very small leeway to get out of the mess
it has built for it so we have built for
ourselves in the last 30 years let us
take a look at how bad that mess is too
let's take a look at the Greek situation
and what appears to be an austerity
program that has not been working the
cuts in Greece have taken their toll
social services have broken down
unemployment has climbed to over
twenty-five percent and pension payouts
are in doubt the new serisa led
government of Alexis tsipras has taken
up its work with ambitious plans they
include a freeze on a series of
privatizations of ports and utilities it
wants to raise the minimum wage and put
an end to endemic corruption but how can
this be reconciled with Greece's mammoth
debt what's the right way ahead for the
country that's the question that is
currently dividing Europe
or Lika Hammond one of the things that
many of greece's partner countries its
creditors have been objecting to is
measures that were taken last week for
example to rehire some public sector
workers in point of fact cleaning ladies
maybe 10,000 or so that was a very small
percentage of the number of public
sector workers who had actually been let
go in the course of reform isn't that
not actually a perfectly understandable
move given the level of misery in Greece
today fifty percent unemployment among
the young 25 percent unemployment
overall doesn't a government have to do
something in the face of misery like
that well yes I mean it's okay that they
rehired those public servants because it
is very obvious that those who were
fired but those who didn't have any
connection to the ruling party to the
Conservatives or to the Social Democrats
who ruled before because of course they
tried to protect their own people and
then fired those who were ya who weren't
protected by any connections up to the
powerful so I think kind of some that
those who were fired and now taking on
again because probably they are those
who are the least corrupt so in any way
it is kind of smart to take them on and
to fire and whatever Farkas said is that
they do do not want to increase the
number of public servants but they want
somehow to have a look at the procedure
that led to these to them being fired
instead of others but in the long run
the number of the public servants will
be the same now to your question about
what can agree government do I mean I
think that this a whole idea of
austerity is always misrepresented you
know the austerity in Greece became
necessary because up to then up to 2009a
Greece lived from loans from outside the
whole model economic economic model was
based on the fact that there was always
new money coming in from outside of
course after the financial crisis and
after it became apparent that degrees
would never ever be able to pay back
these loans there were no new
loans coming so that is basically why
your grease is in such a bad shape
because the form of growth model no
longer works but the problem is that the
new loans that are coming now of course
as you said earlier are simply going to
service the debt in other words it's not
the Greek people who are getting a
bailout it's the creditors of Greece the
banks no in fact if now there was a
haircut and nothing would change because
as I said even interest rates that
Greece pays now I in fact not paid by
Greece but by the other European
countries by giving some small new loans
for Greece to be able to pay its
interest rates so if there was a haircut
and I'm very much in favor for this
writing down the test in Greece and
that's the real problem nothing
absolutely nothing would change the
situation would be just as bad as it is
now and that is something that see pass
and vowels hackers never ever told their
voters that there is just no hope in
order to get grease on a path of growth
that would have to be a whole new
program of development aid and that
would mean new loans coming from outside
Europe would have to be ready to pay
again for Greece and that is really very
difficult to somehow get through because
as mr. Thelen said there are some
countries in the euro zone that are
poorer than trees like Slovakia Lucy
Anya and some of them like Sabathia
being poorer than Greece paid for Greece
so but then they just don't see why they
should continue pain perdu covetous your
new finance minister mr. varoufakis he
would be the first one to say to arica
hammond absolutely right but in fact
it's not new loans we need it's it's aid
it's bill it's a Marshall Plan for
Greece he's calling it the Mackel plan
he's saying Germany needs to behave like
a hegemonic power tell us more about
what he has in mind will tell you but I
have to put one fact straight what
syriza said the government said is that
they're going to rehire ninth
former public servants 600 of them were
the cleaning for which the Greek courts
have decided that they were illegally
sent away and Greece has now 220 if i'm
not mistaken thousand public servants
less than it had in 2010 so it's a small
proportion and there are special cases
the ones who were sent away because they
had no connection with the establishment
now imagine the murder plot the mayor
commercial plan Greece needs a lot more
than a haircut or a Merkel plan Greece
needs to re-engineer the whole system
and in order to re-engineer the whole
system it has to cut away the old system
which is the crony capitalism the
oligarchs the connections between
politicians and and business business
media is also part of this construction
shipping whatever it has to do that if
not no haircut and no growth plan will
help until government taking steps to do
that do you agency but they are the
first ones Ian confuse me is not to give
give money without seeing something yeah
but they have to wait and see it's a
one-week elected government the program
is going to be presented the day after
tomorrow let's wait and see what they
have to say and let's wait and see and
see what they had what they can do
because until now everybody came in
power and grits and said we're gonna
change everything okay nothing happened
not only nothing happened but I have
cases for which of corruption for which
great governments had all the data and
did nothing about it okay let's wait and
see if this government has the guts and
the power and the stamina to go on and
do it well meanwhile there isn't a whole
lot of time for waiting and seeing we
just mentioned februari 28th one of
the many deadlines that it's approaching
and a very very big deadline Damocles
sword hanging over Greece's head this
coming summer when in fact it would need
substantially more money frigid Ailin
this merkel plan that is being proposed
by finance minister varoufakis he
actually looks at Germany's post-war
situation as a kind of model he says
look in the early fifties it became
clear that post-war Germany would never
get out from under the the the effects
of the Second World War unless it got
debt relief number one and number two a
very significant injection of aid in
fact what was the biggest aid program
ever namely the marshall plan is that
parallel in fact a valid one does it
make sense to look at that example and
say you know hey we need a whole
different approach here we do need a
different approach because the trust
you've said that every new government
promised we really find the world we
invent a new word but unfortunately for
years ago for four years later nothing
had been invented so there's distrust
and I doubt very much where you get
where you get this sort of America plan
and second a major question has to be
answered as an Italian movie what went
wrong on the way to the forum something
must have been wrong in Greece different
from other European countries you mean
Slovakia you mean you mentioned a
Portugal writers it Greece is a country
in Europe and it has not been under
communist rule for the last year till
nineteen ninety never been what went
wrong you the Greek must explain the
European public and the rest why all the
money budgets come in to 122 billion and
there's why didn't it work why does
Greek not function and another dimapur
democracies well the main difference
between Germany in 53 and Greece today
is that Germany was destroyed country by
the war but nonetheless it was a former
export nation so you know it was
completely obvious where you had to put
the money into
in you just had to build up the
destroyed industry and then Germany just
continued to function as it had
functioned before and yeah they had
skilled workers they had to know how
they knew how to export what to export
what to produce so it was just a
question of money and in Greece it's
completely different even if one wanted
to invest no one would know what what to
invest in because the industry isn't
there there was industry in the 50s and
60s and it's all gone either to Turkey
or to Bulgaria and there's just nothing
left and you can see that in Greece that
because no one knew where to invest
money they just build streets and
they're a every small path to every
single beach even if there is not a hat
nothing no one noticed nothing the
street to this small beach uninhibited
is a historic and if their valleys with
two streets big number despite the fact
that one street would be enough just
because one didn't know where to put the
money so one just build new roads
because there was a big construction
industry as he said all connected to the
politicians so Greece started building
streets that no one needed and it's
nothing else you can would you agree
that the situation in Greece is
categorically different than the one for
example in Spain and Portugal it is
often said that structural reform is
working in those countries but not in
Greece why why you know I think that's
for historic reasons I mean degrees is
the only country in the eurozone that
had been occupied by the Turkish for
more than 400 years and once yeah but
they are not in the eurozone and that's
what I said yeah the European Union no I
as in the eurozone and and then you know
even the 20th century was very troubled
also due to the for example Germans I
mean it's a we occupied the country it
was horrible for four years hundred
thousands of deaths then after the
Second World War the Greeks voted for
democratically for government
unfortunately it was communist a
communistic government so this year a
intervene
and the result was a civil war so you
know I think that agrees is really
entitled titled to help and I'm really
very much in favor of some kind of
marshall plan a plan but it must be
somehow recognized that would be
something completely different than
anything else the eurozone has ever
undertaken if I read between the lines
here Theodore covetous i'm basically
hearing yes they need help yes they need
debt relief yes they need structural
reform but none of it is going to make a
significant difference even in the
medium term certain certainly not in the
short term maybe not in the medium term
it's a long long-term prospect under
those circumstances can grease really
remain in the eurozone or does do we
need to face the possibility of what's
called Greg's eat Greek exit from the
eurozone not the EU not the European
Union as a whole that is to be seen but
let me make myself absolutely clear I
have said before I believe that Chris
should never have applied to be a member
of the eurozone it was not ready there
was no sustainable cohesion and
convergence with Europe that was a big
myth but since it is in you can't use a
sec two wrongs don't make one right so
we have to see what will come out of
this let me put another dimension 1978
20 dracmus to the deutsche mark 1988 70
trackmaster the deutsche mark 1998
shortly before the eurozone it was a
hundred and seventy the same thing was
valid also for Italy Spain in a lesser
extent but Italy Spain Portugal Ireland
and other countries why because we were
net importers while Germany was a net
exporter the eurozone has no real
mechanism in order to absorb this kind
of permanent situations that is
something we have to see without that I
don't think Greece can stand in the
eurozone because it will have the same
problems again in five years even with a
total haircut or with a shave it doesn't
matter but leaving the political
structure side one could if you are very
pessimistic zip from the infrastructure
from our economy everything Greece is in
a way a failed state I don't talk about
the political parties not about the
democracy but the rest of it is like a
failed state how to put these pieces
together even if the rest of the
Europeans up very well felt was not a
lot of trust into it and not a lot of
Kenneth confidence so it looks at failed
state within the eurozone so what's your
guess a grexit real possibility my guess
is that we have new elections in five
four six months because even the more
this government gets into compromises
his own voters will be very much
deceived thereby they say well that's
not what we voted you into government so
he cannot fulfill bore his promise and
the less sort of the stronger austere
austerity austerity remains this will be
on the negative side of this government
and on the other side he doesn't get the
European help I doubt very much because
of your argument but even if the hacker
and you call it a shave and a new
detergent into the ground it won't work
and no unless and yes unless they what
they do is not only keep the austerity
and clean up the public finances but
also clean up the whole system of
corruption and I'm sure that the voters
if they see that something is really
happening there will not be a new
election snap election okay it's a
little thing it's another financial
thing in fact Theodore Caracas the
finance minister mr. varoufakis he has
used the German analogy and another
respect as well he has said look if we
continue in the situation that we are in
we will not see new elections producing
a moderate middle-of-the-road government
we will see new
shins producing truly extreme parties on
the left and on the right he sees he
certainly wouldn't refer to it as a
failed state but he sees a very strong
potential for political destabilization
do you think that's right he talked
about the Golden Dawn there no Nazis and
because the there is no extreme left in
Greece it if you don't count in the the
Stalinist Communist Party which has a
stable five percent and they have no
dynamics to do with anything else the
there is a risk of social and rest and
please keep in mind that out of the 25
percent of Greeks who are unemployed
only twenty percent of them are entitled
to an unemployment benefit all the rest
have to struggle on their own this is
the reason of course that Greece also
took steps last week after the election
to raise pensions for very poor
pensioners and so on well Rica Hammond
both of the other members of our group
have said they don't think a Greek exit
from the eurozone is in the offing you
told us earlier in the program there's
no hope of these various solutions
actually working so what is the options
that out there would you would you also
say no grexit in store well if one
doesn't know but it grex it will also be
very horrible to grease it would not
really help because in Greece just
doesn't have any export industry the
only expressed in the street has is
tourism now if the degrees left the euro
and have its at me again of course you
know it's very cheap to spend a vacation
yeah but that would be the only affect
the only effect would be that it would
very cheap to spend 20 spend a holiday
spare but apart from that there would be
nothing that Greek agrees a good export
that would also take years and years and
years to develop so it's really a kind
of a very severe situation and I think
that it's very important that the whole
whole of the eurozone somehow gets aware
of that but not only the Europeans but
also
litsa because they didn't tell their
bordeaux's how dire the situation is
Theodore covetous what positive new deal
could be out there what might a new
bargain with Greece look like that of
course the title of our program how do
you see it and we've heard a lot of
demands from the Greeks but what would
they be offering what could they give to
make a new deal possible people think
they have offered whatever they had
because they have the most highly taxed
people in Europe with this in that their
their disposable income has gone down by
forty five to fifty percent actually
unemployment is so high that you cannot
expect any kind of revival financial
revival of public finances at this point
I don't know if Greece has much more to
offer than trying to struggle its way
out of the dire straits and that will
not happen if we go back to the old
system because then no regrets it will
be the the the the lesser of like
demands like this troika demand for
example finance minister varoufakis is
so fond of the German analogy after the
war well Germany was an occupied country
Germany how not only a troika breathing
down its neck it had occupied powers in
its country for decades another surely
Greece could relax its objections to
oversight by the European Central Bank
the European Commission and the
International Monetary Fund those are
the members of the troika what I know
that the great people feel because I see
it around is that they also feel being
under occupation okay because that's no
normal we are a bankrupt state so we
have to listen to what the creditors say
and it's not the first time that Greece
goes bankrupt it's gone bankrupt before
the power company was for decades under
us control
UK control for the water system etc etc
but there is no way that the situation
that now exists can produce anything
better than what it has up to now right
which is why I I want to ask again about
a possible new deal I asked what are
what is Greek off a grease offering well
one thing it has been offering a free
drew stehlin is to swap debt-for-equity
essentially what it's saying is look
we're not going to talk anymore about a
haircut or a write-off of debt we are
going to offer to swap growth indexed
bonds essentially as for some of that
debt now no less an economist then the
Nobel Prize winner Joseph Stiglitz has
said he thinks that is a very very good
idea together with a massive injection
of aid for Greece if it's good enough
for Joseph Stiglitz why shouldn't it be
good enough for Chancellor Merkel and
Finance Minister shortly here in Germany
but even better Stieglitz went wrong we
were not going to end history but there
he committed faults which he admitted
later on but the point is it is a word
game the Greek don't district it it just
not the troika the word but that he just
is he in the program of a storage
austerity that's what they dislike and
it's very difficult if you to read the
swapping what you describe does mean it
is a long term haircut if you never pay
these credits back it's like writing
them off and then adds a situation on
the international markets it's one or
two or three percent for that or that
the Greek government will baying but the
difficulties you won't get any new cover
new new learns new credits than the
community IE european union european
icici be all the rest have to come in
and give a tax payers money into it i
think it's a very very hopeless
situation at the moment because what you
did Annalise is the hopeless situation
of the Ligurian industry where is a hop
coming on the country cannot only live
on until
on what else would they live let me give
you one one fact in nineteen ninety
eight seventy percent of our glucotrol
products consumed in Greece were
produced internally 2010 that was thirty
percent the same goes for many
industries shoe industry clothing
industry it's also global factors which
go in but you know why was that because
of the sale the idea of a free meal
wages went up forcibly went up in Greece
after it entered the euro and the whole
thing was not working out it was not
economical to produce Derka Berka is
very briefly because we're almost out of
time how much time do we have to get
this new deal up and working when does
the clock right now it goes boom okay
thank you very much for being with us
today and thank you for being for
joining us as well to all of you out
there see you soon and undoubtedly to
discuss this ongoing situation hopefully
before it goes boom thanks a lot bye bye